sometimes seeing people from Britain and
stuff it seemed like they're not real
I don't mean like you guys aren't real
people yeah yeah and I believe in you it
reminds me of like Paddington Bear
hello everybody as you can see we've got
more American with every day of the trip
like Freedom uh indeed we have an
incredible day yesterday uh we went to
the biggest gun show in the United
States yep there they are thank you
Bosch ladies
uh we also find what he's doing we need
to get more women on the platforms
[Music]
love it now so we find some guns it was
great we went to the gun show yeah yeah
then we were supposed to go the
beautiful sebi mcorker who was an
awesome thing absolutely and the whole
family frankly we were supposed to go to
the gun range with him yeah but when we
turned up we turned out it wasn't just a
gun range there was a command to master
sergeant of the U.S Navy Seals
in his late 60s you could still choke
you around about two seconds
you hear the metal foot he's basically
the Terminator yeah anyway he trained us
we shot some blocks yeah shot some m4s
at G36 and the Desert Eagle which
actually and by the way it turns out
Anton is the best shot out of all of us
yeah I did okay yeah Francis had some
good ones yeah I was a monster in the
headshot mate yeah when aiming for the
chest yeah but it's still a headshot
so now we're at the airport in
Washington about to put a plane to go
and see Big Joe yeah Joey we're coming
for you this is a small drink in the
United States yeah do you know what I've
never felt more thin I'm moving here
[Music]
quick update so it's four hours later we
should have been in Austin by now but
instead we're still in Washington
because we sat on a plane before and
they told us it was broken it's a
globalist left his conspiracy
that's what it is you're absolutely
they're trying to stop us from spreading
the truth but we're Freedom fires and
we're never gonna stop now everyone's
looking at us like we're weirdos thanks
to this epic easier they can't even
pronounce idiots that's how stupid you
are
and no doubt someone will come out and
agree with this sure yeah so there we
are because that's the beauty of the
internet there's truth Seekers
everywhere
oh I forgot to say so there's going to
be another plane
maybe what snacks have you got there
Francis
every kind of snack I didn't buy this
because I wouldn't buy skinny because
I'm a man
[Music]
all right so we're mid-flight as you can
see We're In First Class thanks to Big
Joey but we're gonna land in Austin in a
couple of hours we're going to get in uh
we're gonna get some rest because we've
been staying up late and uh having a lot
of fun tomorrow we're meeting Colby
Hamilton and Chris Williamson and then
Tuesday two days from now and we're
meeting uh the man himself
foreign
Texas
so we are in the land of big Joey Rogan
we are
so here we are in Austin we're about to
meet one of our big supporters Colby
Hamilton we have been taking the piss
out of him for the last three years so
hopefully it doesn't shoot us it's just
too hot in it you know how hot it is
I've got two sunglasses mate I don't
think it has anything to do with the
here unless it's melted your brain no
mate it's too hot I've got two sets of
sunglasses just because that's how
butthole it is mate I can't take it it's
not [ __ ] natural Gary I'm with
Extinction Rebellion this [ __ ] needs to
end I want to go on mate we're about to
eat how do you feel about that
too little too like what it's too little
too late this is unnatural the heat has
broken them guys I'm not my pudgy Irish
body isn't designed for this we're in
Washington I've been eaten by mosquitoes
look at that it looks like I've got
monkey pox mate
[ __ ] had enough what do you do with
them it's been [ __ ] the mosquitoes
anyway let's go and have some food with
Colby
[Music]
I'm hungry we're hungry and Colby's late
I'm hungry Colby what's wrong with you
you never get between a pancetta and his
food mate what's going on I think Texans
were meant to be polite that's what they
all bang on about southern manners
Southern well I'm not seeing anything
they've all got guns that is true but at
this point I reckon I'll just terminate
them through it it just bounce off me
you've eaten a lot but not that much I'm
getting angry now Colby
where are you cobby's gonna sit on you
mate watch out exactly and not in a
sexual way there he is
we're just talking about you mate so
here we are the man himself
how's it holdinator uh he's given us a
gift and I'll be honest with you I'm a
bit worried because it's ticking no he's
not ticking let's have a look it's
perpetual now Kobe's got the man there
he is oh there he goes Toby's always
packing is it three of the same thing no
they're different
oh it's the hot sauce oh man pineapple
and habanero Crimson hot sauce what is
this right okay
this looks like it could be part of a
gun it was part of a gun
tell the other night I poured out too
far on the trigger so it can no longer
be okay so it's been cut in half this is
AR-15 all right yeah so we got this hole
drilled we got this holder we got this
whole drill but if you look in the top
there I went too far on the trigger and
the trigger mechanism won't right won't
hold so Colby would like us to take an
AR-15 back to the UK
would be boisterous laughing and All For
Your Glory in Jesus name amen amen that
was good that was great man
so our drinks have arrived look at this
this is what Real Men drink yeah exactly
with the flowers in it yeah yeah we're
just finished on me with Colby the
Hamilton this is a very problematic top
level Frizzle we had a great chat and
now he's going to give us a lift home so
that I can have a nap both of us are
going to have a nap are you gonna have
not together yeah go go to ride in my
car.com right now and catch the live
streams the food now is not only great
but about a quarter of the price we paid
for a mediocre Mexican in New York which
is obviously much more important yeah
you come to Austin [ __ ] New York
can argue with that
but we've come for coffee I thought this
is a great place to have coffee me and
Tony you know we're gonna I'm gonna do a
little bit of coffee go 4.5 on uh the
old TripAdvisor wherever it was this is
where it [ __ ] sent us
what is this this looks like the place
you have coffee if you're a myth it's a
[ __ ] disgrace I've walked about four
minutes in the Blazing heat I'm already
covered in mosquito bites I'm sweaty
just want a coffee
is this
I've had enough mate what way is that is
it this way
so we found it it was just it was
literally just next door
[Music]
in the 90s Australians came in I mean we
were dreadful for food and everything in
the UK apart from if you wanted to get
hammered you know that's what we do you
know so Australians came over in the 90s
and had our coffee and went mate or
disease it's disgusting and then they
brought Coffee Culture from places like
Melbourne and Sydney to London so we've
actually got really good coffee now
that's awesome yeah yeah so it's it's
good apart from if you go to a chain in
this disgusting but if you know a good
place to go it's it's nice
yeah cool thank you so we're in Texas
Coffee Traders and it's a really
interesting place because obviously
you've got the retail side of it where
you can order coffee and you've got all
the different coffees there but also
what they do is they transport and they
distribute coffee all over Texas
different types of coffee you can see
what they've got here so we're gonna get
a coffee it smells like it's going to be
delicious because the coffee we had
earlier today was
so I'm really looking forward to it
you're looking forward to a coffee Tony
good stuff let's go get one okay so what
we've got you've got your classic
espresso you've got your Americana the
macchiato accordado I can't remember
what cortado is uh cappuccino latte
mocha but if you say mocha in America no
one understands you you have to say
mocha because otherwise people just look
at you like you've had in like kind of
an aneurysm straight karato
I don't know what that is in a frappe
so here we go mate problem is I've just
noticed thanks to you mate I've realized
I'm growing boobs so I was going to get
a mocha as I say over here
probably gonna get a latte yeah if they
do
um contou milk
I don't know I think Austin's pretty
liberal
swearing in Texas yeah I don't know
remember watches these does your mum
yeah yeah Ally mum
[Music]
New Yorkers are aggressive aggressive
yeah you'll do something to a London and
I'll just go
do that that's how we live our life
you'll know if like you're really
annoyed a group of londoners because
you're here
[Music]
it just sounds like a clock
[Music]
that is a good coffee tell you what I
think my prostate Has Smiled to twice
the size after this little baby
[Music]
alright so we had a little break and now
we're here with our friend of Chris
Williamson indeed of modern I was going
to say of modern wisdom and then I
thought I was about to get his YouTube
show named wrong and then I thought you
know I'll pause it there that's how much
we love you man how are you doing man
yeah we're great it's good to be here
we're about to go and take our tops off
to next to Chris which I'm not I mean
I'm gonna be like the fat kid in the
swimming pool I'll keep the top on are
you doing the wet t-shirt company yeah
I'm gonna do the wet t-shirt competition
we need to bring that back you've got
the boobs for it yeah exactly feminism
has crushed male fun let's get the tits
out for the lads
so I'm gonna take the boys into a kuya
which is a sauna an ice bath place and
we're going to do three rounds of 20
minutes in the sauna at about 200
degrees and then they're going to get
into basically freezing cold water for
three minutes yes and we will test the
Russian Mite I've done this before man
yeah yeah I love it yeah I'm not sure
about three minutes in Nicole though
you'll survive
I mean I have higher Ambitions than that
oh here we are okay okay yeah so we're
gonna go and do that all right great
it's going now we're going for dinner uh
tell us when we're going for dinner
Terry Black's Barbecue mmm Yum Yum Yum's
favorite place so let's get on with it
cool let's do it
[Music]
one hour later all right so we've done
the sauna and cold plunge it was
incredible we're both feeling very
rested I feel hungry and very [ __ ]
angry because I'm hungry mate I don't
know what Chris is doing to me trying to
talk to me mate so not for me two stars
uh by the way Francis just came out of
there and Chris was saying to him you
were really quiet in there is everything
all right and France was like oh yeah I
was meditating
so it's clearly working
peaceful same very Zen it's nice to see
the boys nice to see everyone out here
it's great to see you man how did you
how did they do Chris they did good man
I mean you did great you were very very
good the first time that both of them
dropped in there was a lot of heavy
breathing but I'm sure that that's just
par for the course in the trigonometry
office
and now we're gonna go to Terry Black's
Barbecue and I think everyone's ready
for a meat that is served by weight so
pounds of meat
what you think about that Francis
I think Chris is ready to redeem himself
all right so we've arrived at Terry
Black's
smells like pepper so we're gonna go in
charge Heaven chod carcinogenic heaven
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
babies are wild so I get my wife to send
me a video every morning okay and I
usually find myself talking to the phone
yeah
and so the wanky thing that all people
with kids always say and you go shut the
[ __ ] up but it's true it changes who you
are unbelieving did we talk about this
when you interview me I think I remember
saying it too but maybe not so literally
the day I found out that my wife's
pregnant I was driving to the studio and
at that time our studio was in this
really rough part of East London is that
the one I went through that's the one
right you remember that was quite a
rough area a little bit yeah yeah and
I'm driving and this guy cuts me Cuts in
front of me he did tell me this yeah
yeah and I just found myself reacting
that it wasn't like we almost died no I
need to it was just like I reacted
differently yeah it changes Who You Are
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I guess that's the closest thing that
you have to a Texas local now which is a
sad State of Affairs what I think we've
got here is a pint of green beans and a
pint of the famous Terry blacks coleslaw
this is some Mexican rice that's two
pints of their mac and cheese which is
absolutely spectacular this is supposed
to be a beef rib but looks like
something that Fred Flintstone would eat
that's a I am Fred Flintstone you are
now the Russian Fred yes Fred
Vladimir Flintstone this is some chopped
beef that we've got that's a pint there
that's a pound and a half of beef
brisket some jalapeno cheese sausage and
some turkey in the middle there with a
bunch of the Terry blacks in-house
barbecue sauces and Richard's sparkling
rain water which is Elite level
rainwater so that was Texas of an
evening as I could have given the boys
so good it's genuinely melt in the mouth
everybody always uses a word melt in the
mouth dishes
always spectacular
sit down and eat as you can see by
looking at all three of our foreheads
we've got the meat sweats because we
went into this incredible place thanks
to our friend Chris it was awesome the
conversation even better we can't wait
to have Chris on the show because he's a
very interesting and very intelligent
guy can't wait to do that and he's got
some incredible news which we can't tell
you but they are incredible aren't they
it's gender fluid exactly got a big day
tomorrow we're gonna go and see big Joey
whose favorite place apparently this is
in Austin and that is it for the night
take care and we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
what I did what is I went to the taco
place what were we doing today that I
found yeah it's a taco place that he
found yeah which we had yesterday
they're three dollars each I mean it's
just coming back from New York where it
was painful the prices in New York were
genuinely late my wallet was hurting my
it was hurting me I was just seeing it
in the bus stop someone appeared out of
nowhere that'll be fifty dollars pretty
soon yeah I didn't like it anyway here
we are in Austin Texas we're having sex
breakfast this is I don't know what
Anton's doing but anyways now we've got
a different angle so we're in our Airbnb
Francis and Anton just went and got some
more of these tackers yesterday we had
Cactus chorito and uh cheese and you had
Cactus and spinach and the moment where
you like bite into this three dollar
taco and you go oh my word this is
heaven I'm gonna be as fat as Francis
this is great you know why it looks like
we've just made a drug deal and it makes
me feel better than drugs that how good
it is anyway so we're going to smash a
bunch of these we've got something going
on today don't we yeah we're
interviewing
interview well we are yeah in the
evening what we've got
off we do have to go and see a mate
we're seeing big joey yes Joey and it's
at 12 o'clock so we need to get some
food into us we got some proper food
into us before we go I'm gonna Rob his
head for love just before we do the
interview oh my head no he's mate don't
rub my head off
yeah we haven't brought a pool cue
flying time no Joey either have we no
that was meant to be exclusive content
yeah Joe Rogan versus scouter with a
pool cue anyway that probably won't
happen but we're gonna have some
breakfast a Navy SEAL allegedly is
coming to pick us up in an hour I'll
[ __ ] him up because I'm our karate
anyway as I was saying uh he's coming to
pick us up in an hour we'll go and see
Big Joe it's going to be two to three
hours we reckon
and then we bit back here a quick snack
and then interview the Yvonne and then
tomorrow we're off to Nashville yeah to
see the feminist icon that is Matt Walsh
oh will she will she will she Posey's
gonna be happy oh of course she is
anyway we're gonna ask her what a bird
is anyway enough talk we've got to get
stuck into this take care see you after
Rogan
all right this has got some pink [ __ ] in
it why did you put pink shirt in what
you got me a pink coffee cup and then
pink [ __ ] in my tackle what are you
trying to do to me mate right not
[ __ ] gay guys don't like it this is
Cactus chorizo and that's when we had
lots of cheese oh oh so we've all got
one of them look at this little slaggy
oh lovely all right let's get some of
this action don't make noises like that
it's enough to have to hear it when
we're back home and you're there with
pumpkin doing that yeah
then Francis I know you're not Jewish
but you've got to admit the fact that
it's three dollars makes it better of
course you know the best thing actually
if there was a Mexican woman there
serving busted out the linger she loved
it yeah of course I spoke to her in
Spanish and I said to her you know my
friend it was in Mexico and he said
there was no difference between your
tacos and Mexicans attacks the tacos and
she looked at me went yes I know
and she just looked at me I'm like
thanks love just gave you a compliment
there and you just showed me she was
just trying to work out where you look
like John Oliver's nephew who's up on a
charge what a great day we had with
Chris yesterday yeah man that was
incredible Chris is one of the most
high-functioning human beings I've ever
met his business his mindset his
incredible guns um
with a body like that he should be going
I don't really see a lot of strike
blokes with those with that body mate
what about Anton
just because he's hairy that is true
and they can be gay together
we'll be talking it's a hard question it
is
I'm getting close to the end of this
sequence
[Music]
Anton would be bottom it's great
well Greeks lover both ways Anton is a
bit smaller yeah but I'm trying to think
who's more dominant yeah and I've never
experienced either of them in that way
it's true maybe what we need to do is
get Anton to watch Everton lose to four
nil to Minnesota United yeah then you'd
be then you'd be a problem no you'd be
that angry yeah he would be tonight it's
your turn to take a battering Anton come
and have one of these slangs come on
mate this is yours Cactus chorizo and
cheese it is insane right that is Tokyo
sex while I absolutely phenomenal
in shine
so we are about to go the cars outside
uh we're off to see big Joey Joey's son
we're coming for you
what do we do now don't don't say Joey's
son
's your dad call him daddy yeah tell him
daddy we're coming for you that sounds
even worse all right we'll see you after
[Music]
so this is post Rogan we're rolling now
all right so we've just come off Joe
Rogan four and a half hours my platter I
mean it was getting to the point where
it was unsustainable frankly but four
and a half hours what a conversation we
talked about the politics we talked
about comedy we talked about the
universe as you can probably tell from
the state of both of us you sparked up a
joint halfway through and we've got
absolutely mashed We Had the Time of Our
Lives we're both Sky High we're both
stunned and now we have to interview
Clio Von yeah I have never once been
mashed at all when interviewing a guest
so as we don't smoke weed in the UK yeah
it's illegal yeah it's illegal yeah
because it's writtenish naughty somehow
we're gonna have to conduct a serious
but fun interview whilst I'm in this
state I've got no idea we're going to do
it I can't even remember this is simple
man we're just gonna go Theo mate what
do you reckon about aliens yeah yeah be
our aliens uh let's cancel culture maybe
should we talk about or maybe not mate
let's just how are you mate fear is
coming we've got a [ __ ] all time to set
up we'll see you on the other side
that's crazy man what is sometimes team
people from Britain and stuff it seems
like they're not real
you know what I'm saying Connor oh you
can't know it because I don't mean like
you're real people yeah yeah and I
believe in you yeah but I just like it
reminds me of like Paddington Bear right
and he's British isn't he yeah no mate
he's originally from Peru all right so
we've just come from a very odd week
interview with Thea Von very strange
anyway so we did Theo that was odd yeah
and I think it's partly because we were
stunned but also he has a very
interesting way of looking at life very
unusual to most of the guests that we
have on that was awesome and now we're
here at Big Joey's Club to see an
awesome show uh Joe and Theo python it's
going to be awesome yeah man I'm still
off my nuts we had one of our biggest
ever guests on and I can only speak in
two and three syllables so nothing has
changed you know how amazing today has
been we haven't eaten since 11 o'clock
and he hasn't said a [ __ ] word that's
right I'm hungry
all right so it is approaching midnight
we have just seen a [ __ ] amazing show
at Joe Rogan's Comedy Club here safe to
say every single would you agree with me
every single set of every single
comedian would get them banned from
every single comedy club in the UK man
it was so inspiring just to come here to
experience it to be on Joe's show
incredible it was darling
it was amazing very friendly people as
you can see especially John Oliver
exactly anyway we're going to the golden
tiger baby and we're going to get some
[ __ ] hamburgers what a day
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
recommended we're gonna go home we're
gonna go sleep and tomorrow morning we
get up hop on a plane to Nashville and
hopefully interview big Matty to watch a
very very very special day and we'll be
on the road again tomorrow take care
have a good night
[Music]
I don't know why he's saying boss I'm
calling us a taxi bye
[Music]